one star who says you're never gonna
catch her shopping like that is Raya
Carrie it is work not fit for a music
diva besides she had so much on her
plate right now a wedding her Vegas
residency a reality show and we wanted
to hear all about her glam life so we
set mariah down with our favorite
daytime diva the talks Sharon Osbourne
what should I wait in the waiting I just
don't come in a bridal gown so do you
think that you've got time this year to
actually do that I mean that's the goal
what was it love at first sight we
didn't really it was it he was dealing
with his stuff I don't I wasn't like on
the prowl like what are we doing you
know I mean it's just you meet people
and I was like oh this guy is really fun
this uh this it was nice we all know
Mimi likes to call the shots but will
she when she becomes the missus to
billionaire businessman James Packer
what you doing what you do and he does
what he does is he gonna wear the
trousers oh darling how can you ask me
that question of course he'll wear his
trousers and I'll wear whatever ensemble
I'm going to wear
I've got to say you're in amazing shape
you know well casting like wise to you
but I've been working hard so yeah you
look amazing you know the funny thing is
like with me I would always be like oh I
gained weight like I because I'm
muscular so I don't really like
sometimes I don't even notice it and now
I've been pretty consistent with this
bleak diet that a month okay that League
diet is working me Nia's never looked
better
she's back at Caesar's Palace with her
number one to infinity residency that
continues through the summer at first I
was like three shows away like it was
every other night or something but it
really I do need them oh I know I know
you thought you could arrest that voice
I do to us but what will never rest is
always looking fab from head to toe if I
would have got the note about bringing
sunglasses because these diamonds are
like blinding me that my best friends I
had to bring them now the curtain will
be pulled back on Mimi's glittery life
her docu-series airs on e later this
year if the most important event that's
ever happened it's really been kind of
fun because I had an interesting yet
great time on tour so that's documented
for me for the rest my life but just how
real is mariahs world when was the last
time you went grocery shopping truth
come on we have a link to a real ghost
restore grocery shopping it's very bad
lighting in the coast have you not
noticed it's fluorescent lighting tell
me you go to the grocery store when you
can't beat those two together that is
exactly what I expected from a sit-down
with Sharon Osbourne of Mariah Carey
right now I'll go to the grocery store
for book y'all know where there you go